[Music]
in awkward first date news states are
always are submitted by Patrick Starr
virtual reality dating is now a thing
whoa I feel like you mean like when you
go on the Sims game and you go make a
second life yeah
oh yes ii myself I think it's like VR
[ __ ] though sir but that goggle over
yeah yeah you got like the HTC vive or
whatever yeah it's like the whole getup
did you guys ever play war ii warcraft
yeah you know when I played EverQuest
dude I'm a [ __ ] loser like you know
when you when you quite online you know
when you quest with like a female
character and you're like you're
actually kind of cool and then like you
get there Facebook or whatever and
you're like dad that's not what I
imagined I'll tell you this though yeah
it's a game that's your face huh
I'll tell you why the story didn't
actually get to bring it up to this guy
but I found out after they broke up so I
was friends with there's this dude and
this girl and they broke up
because this wasn't the reason why they
broke up but it was the catalyst how it
started but one day she started to
getting suspicious that her boyfriend
was cheating right and then he was
looking back and forth like an opponent
he was out of nowhere he was grab his
phone like just suspicious and she's
like what the [ __ ] was that about she
let her I found out that she was he was
cheating on her with the girl somewhere
across seas that he found through World
of Warcraft no and then she was like I
don't she was so pissed cuz she didn't
know how to feel she's yeah I'm mad
because I got cheated on I'm also mad
because I got cheated by someone who
doesn't really exist [ __ ] this [ __ ]
looks like yeah so she was like I kind
of wish thing this girl wasn't ugly
[ __ ] you know be like do you prefer
getting cheated on by a pretty girl an
ugly girl right so if it's a pretty girl
it's like okay she's prettier than me
but if it's other girls like what the
[ __ ] yeah how [ __ ] is made you knows
like what yeah you did it to Maurice
right yeah you've always cheat uglier
they always go
yeah well because you can do more [ __ ]
up [ __ ] sexually to them oh that's right
because they'll get it I get a why
that's what the saying say is it's like
they cheat under because the ugly girl
will just about suck anything but
there's some [ __ ] that tip I won't say
because use they're off Cameron
confidence but there's some [ __ ] that
tip won't do sexually and you know what
for Casey
all go get her yeah yeah yeah you're not
getting [ __ ] anywhere you [ __ ] up
no you don't miss it I'll give that weed
back with the full report
yeah the fly-fishing game couple years
ago many years ago called Star Wars
Galaxies okay and that you could play
online in the star was you know it's
finally becoming her but are you ready
to find out what pimp ass [ __ ] I
used to do back then so two people were
getting married in the game and I found
out about this via the message boards
and so me and my brother went to the
wedding and we established a role what
is called a role play with each other
where everyone's like lined up for the
on the aisle and I sat down in one spot
and then I know my brother said done one
spot and then I walked up to my brother
knows like excuse me sir you're sitting
in my seat and he was like oh no I'm not
I've actually been here for a while and
I'm like sir
you're absolutely in my seat I was here
and then I had to get up real quick and
then now I'm back and we're all set
we're typing all this in game Wow and
then meanwhile the bride and groom are
like walking down the [ __ ] aisle and
I'm and he's like we're gonna have to
take this inside knows like we're gonna
take this right here and we both whipped
out our guns in the middle of the game
shooting each other with the guns right
and we're and we're like straight circle
strafing around the bride and groom like
as we should be
ruining their wedding but because we use
a type of weapon that we weren't
certified to use or whatever you do no
damage to each other so you see all the
blaster bolts fire and we're doing rolls
and [ __ ] shooting soda rocket launchers
and [ __ ] no damage and we did this [ __ ]
for like [ __ ] 35 minutes and I was
laughing so hard I was crying I'm not
stopping because this man upset me and
upset my honor and [ __ ] so I used their
stupid [ __ ] role-playing rules
because that way I wouldn't get banned
from the game because I was role-playing
too and they were role-playing
I didn't know any of this before I
played these games so I could [ __ ] with
people I've been doing it my whole life
neutral mess it's a blast yeah so
anyways she still she's still upset
about the heavy lunch thing bro I see it
I see it in the I get like physically
seeing just quiet
oh we're cool looks not even all this
video you'll have to watch a different
JK news video to see why I'm so mad at
him you don't get [ __ ] I'm gonna get
anything so there's this online series
which recently launched on Facebook
watch have you guys heard of Facebook
watch know that apparently it's like a
place on Facebook where you can watch
things TV shows TV show oh you're
watching you with people online I think
they're trying to start some streaming
service for you tag this I think it's
more like Netflix I'm not too sure but
anyways this series has been launched
its called virtually dating it's a show
by condé nast entertainment and I'm
gonna show you guys a little clip of it
total strangers
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
that's an interesting yeah so you guys
can watch on Facebook watch I wonder if
people are disappointed with the
real-life version that's the whole game
like 3d print like 3d creative get an
idea but that's not I'm saying your
psyche so you're someone you're the on
the beginning of your relationship is
based on on stuff that aren't isn't real
you know so the heightened sense is here
when you first start relationship is
real and beginning it is very first day
it's always [ __ ]
ours wasn't but it we knew each other
for like four years I don't think it's
[ __ ] it's just that you're getting
to know somebody for the first time so
it's real it's just different you know
so this is completely unreal you know so
now I start to wonder like because you
have such a high stimulus from all this
like crazy game activity and then you go
into the real life is it like oh well
this guy's the first one dude you can't
how do you say it out loud to it's like
weird you guys amazing it's like a long
thing is explaining person that's like I
did people for their personalities and
then this thing really tests that
like you you know could totally fall in
love with someone's personality and then
not be attracted to them 100% cuz you
best believe my virtual reality self has
a six-pack every one of these every one
of these [ __ ] in the show
should be pre interviewed and it's like
it's like how important is personality
though it's the most important yeah
basically interviewed beforehand call
out their [ __ ] I want to see a guy
that says that cuz they want they have
to be real and say if she doesn't make
me horny I can't be with them absolutely
that's the honest truth
that's the honest goddamn truth yeah
personality does play a huge factor but
there has to be some type of physical
attraction whether it's like 30 percent
or 40 percent it has to be there I mean
that always if I really really like her
personality then she's like cousin yeah
they were like I'm like never I've never
been attracted to someone like right off
the bat like physically just I'm on
being that person it's always been they
have to make me laugh like once someone
makes me laugh they can be like pretty
ugly and I'll be like yeah you're making
me inverse laugh right now like it's
going away like it's fading over here
did you hear my star wars online story
yet
yeah my vagina's slowly closing up I
stopped the wedding though they called
it off that's pretty pimp I think that's
pretty hardcore you you won I stopped
the wedding one completely online
wedding I've complete strangers I
stopped the wedding but they had to
reschedule a story so many times it's
like [ __ ] is closing you but I'm we're
rolling to the blast door just in time
dude just in time
I forgot my hat
[Laughter]
mrs. I miss those what you could do it
in that virtual round yeah so if you
look like an idiot like you look like
it's keeping you alive
like why does it have to be you don't
mean you don't look that much less of an
idiot without it on you know what you
know what sold me though is that girl
was a polar bear yes they changed like
bodies yeah if I could be a [ __ ]
elephant or something else and then
you're getting to know me as elephant
Joe that's very good exactly as I'm
saying like personality actually plays a
big role in and you've like fallen for
this would you want guys want to be if
you were in this show Oh
face face I'd be a dragon so kind of
mystical were like where and what I
would say in space with all stars and
stuff because I say and I'll be a
mermaid I'd be integral is ii-in address
so it's like whoa that's it that is that
same concept they put these clothes
again you got the fly right just get out
of there jump for the speed back it
would have to be something a long way
don't know man
tractor wigs it's gotta be a place that
you can't visit because you've seen
Egypt so it looks hokey yeah it's like
it looks waterproof Egypt I would want
to go to Willy Wonka's factory oh I just
you know the candy and walk down a
little [ __ ] yeah you can't taste
anything now that's us I know yeah I
want to be inside a happy marriage
[Laughter]
what's up you sexy [ __ ] useless
[ __ ] [ __ ] if you want to
follow us you could check out all our
[ __ ] leaks at the description box
below you [ __ ] [ __ ] and then that
videos are up there
[Music]